the South Africa spy cables have given
us amazing access to their inner working
they tell a story of incompetence lack
of transparency security failings and if
you thought the NSA was the only
governmental organization to spy on its
citizens you were wrong
the spy cables say the SSA does act in
accordance with South African law great
but agents can spy on anyone they like
and breaks a law which they have
provided to get a letter from their line
manager it also says the director
general of the SSA can approve any
deviation from the provisions of this
policy South Africa has bigger ambitions
- and it's called project Condor full
name huh built with the Russians and
costing one hundred million dollars it's
a satellite shrouded in secrecy one that
would allow the South Africans the
capability to spy over all of Africa but
the document seems to indicate that the
deal was between South African military
intelligence and Russian intelligence
and that the SS a the civilian agency
has to spy on the Russian government to
find out what was going on and whether
construction of the satellite was
getting anywhere
incompetent much that's not all a secret
internal report shows corruption and
foreign espionage is deep there have
also been major security failings within
the agency foreign spies have had total
freedom of access to ministry's
parliament and security installations
the cables show the agency and its
Ethiopian counterparts also screwed up
when they almost failed to protect the
chairman of the African Union South
African politician in closes honorable
emini Zuma after an eminent threat to
her life in addis ababa wait till you
hear what they were doing when they were
meant to protect her and how about the
global so-called war on terror south
africa has nothing to do with that right
well the cable showed the SSA keeps an
eye on a list of South African
individuals it suspects of being
involved with al-qaeda
East Africa the SSA also spies on the
tablature not a Muslim group that is
notoriously apolitical
so in South Africa spy agency unique or
are they all like this behind the veil
of secrecy what do you think